nothing to see here just the nation's
two top democrats questioning election
integrity biden in his embarrassing
speech and press conference yesterday
cast doubt
on whether the 2022 midterm results
would be legitimate if his divisive
voting rights legislation wasn't passed
if this isn't passed do you still
believe the upcoming election will be
fairly conducted and its results will be
legitimate
well it all depends on uh
whether or not
we're able to
make
the case to the american people that
some of this is being set up to try to
alter the outcome of the election the
increase
in the prospect of being illegitimate is
a direct proportion of us not being able
to get these
these reforms passed
man i can still barely make it through
that clip
but it's all a power play he's trying to
scare you by making you think
if his agenda doesn't go through
elections will be rigged
and america will be facing a doomsday
scenario but joe's bills were blocked
rightfully by the senate yesterday
thanks not just to republicans but to
democrats
that didn't stop joe's next in charge
from of course spewing the same exact
rhetoric today kamala blew up at an nbc
host this morning in a round of media
what do you what shall we call them
rehab interviews
the issue is that there are two bills
the john lewis voting rights act and the
freedom to vote act
that have been
the the solution that has been offered
to address the fact that around our
country states have put in place laws
that are purposely making it more
difficult for the american people to
vote the bills were debated and they
didn't pass
if
but the specific question if you don't
mind
does he think now that these bills
haven't been passed that the 22 midterms
won't be legitimate or fair or free
let's not conflate issues
are we really surprised by any of this
liberals have been undermining faith in
our elections for decades it's kind of
something they do
i'm very interested to know what is
happening with the absentee ballots
there are too many allegations of
irregularities my advice to al is
you keep fighting you can run the best
campaign
you can even become the nominee
and you can have the election stolen
from you
concession means to say that the process
was fair i am complicit if i say that
that system is fair
that was the governor of georgia she
thinks she is and that was hillary
clinton in 2019 three years later
you see it never ends
but as for joe
don't worry about him his team did even
more damage control
he absolutely is not predicting that the
2022 elections would be illegitimate
point he was making is that the former
president asked a number of states seven
or more in fact to overturn the outcome
of the election uh now obviously if
there's an effort to do that we've got
to fight against that that's what our
commitment is to doing but he was not
making a prediction he has confidence in
the american people and we're going to
do everything we can to protect people's
rights
but the damage is already done
joe's team can't clean up this mess
anymore he and vice president giggles
have already said what they really
believe
and america heard them loud and clear
the first time the second time in the
third time joining me now missouri
missouri gop senator
josh hawley senator thanks so much for
being here
after all of that what did you hear
well what i heard was what joe biden
said loud and clear which is he's
already making excuses for why he's
going to lose in november and pete
that's what this is all about democrats
don't accept elections that they don't
win i mean it happened in 2000 it
happened in 2004 it happened in 2016.
now it's going to be 2022. i mean if joe
biden thought that his party was going
to win these elections then all would be
fine but he thinks and because the poll
suggests he's going to lose them his
party's going to lose in the house and
the senate and therefore they're
illegitimate i mean it's it's dangerous
it's wrong it's ridiculous and everybody
knows it's ridiculous and yet there he
is out there saying it
absolutely right
yet for them 2020 totally above board uh
but kamala says now this is an amazing
clip she uh something she said in one of
the interviews about when she talks to
world leaders
they're questioning our voting system
listen to kamala harris
i've met with prime ministers and
presidents from around the globe both
partners and allies of ours they are
asking
what is going on with voting rights in
america they are monitoring to wonder
and question whether there is an erosion
of our democracy and therefore an
erosion of one of the best role models
of what a democracy does and can do
so so senator could it be that they're
calling the white house because kamala
harris and joe biden keep saying
uh and building a straw man about their
own legislation that creates confusion
in the world that my goodness i don't
know in america certain people are
blocked at the polls and not allowed to
vote
yeah you know i'm not sure that i really
believe that little story the vice
president just told there but that's
true if that is happening i bet world
leaders do have a lot of questions they
probably wonder who the heck is in
charge in this white house because it
doesn't appear to be the president of
the united states and it sure doesn't
appear to be the vice president of the
united states so who is really running
the show
and after this disastrous first year i
mean the american people want to know
what is going on and this is why they're
in such trouble come november but the
bottom line is this pete that our
democracy is strong that the american
people are are strong and in charge and
their votes are the ones that count
their voices are the ones that matter
and to try to delegitimize those ahead
of time to try to say that whatever
decision the american people come to in
november is illegitimate because you
don't think you're going to like the
outcome of it boy that is playing with
fire and that's exactly what the
democrats are doing and unfortunately
they have a history of doing that of
thinking they know better than the
american people do and that's just the
same song 50th verse that we're hearing
from him again
you're exactly right senator that's
exactly what joe biden said from the
podium he effectively said we need to
explain this in even more simple terms
because people just don't understand how
awesome we are
that seems to be the refrain they always
come up with senator josh hawley thanks
for your time appreciate it tonight
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else